In this video we will get to know the concept of entropy.
At first the idea of ​​entropy
may seem a little mysterious.
But after a couple of videos, I hope you start to understand
on an intuitive level as it is entropy.
Much of the definition of entropy
revolve around the word "disorder".
We can assume that entropy is the disorder of a system.
Only with this definition in mind
I want you to pause the video and try to compare it
these two systems.
I want you to compare this room with this one
and ask yourself which one has greater entropy.
Then I want you to compare the Moon and the Sun here.
Obviously they are not in real scale, as the Sun
would be much more massive and bigger,
if the pictures were on the right scale.
But which of these two systems is more entropy?
Okay, I guess he's already tried.
Looking at the two rooms,
at first glance it seems to us that this room is arranged here.
This is a clean room.
And this one seems to be messy, messy.
With this definition of entropy, you probably thought it was
if there is more disorder in this room,
it's probably more entropy.
And not only do you think so.
In fact, many textbooks use the example of a stacked and messy room.
And the scattered room is considered a room with greater entropy.
But it is not exactly the case.
This "disorder" here is different
from this "mess".
I will emphasize this to make you quite clear.
Scattered
is not equal to entropy.
To understand what "disorder" means in the sense of entropy,
we will have to work a little more on how to imagine it.
But I hope it will become clear.
In entropy, disorder is determined by the number of states a system can accept.
What do I mean under system state?
Let's say I have a box.
In it four molecules move in all directions.
One molecule is pink, the other blue,
this one here is yellow,
and this is green.
This is a particular situation,
specific configuration.
But in this system the molecules move
and may take up other configurations.
To take other states.
The yellow molecule may have come here,
blue here,
pink may already be here,
and the green molecule is now here.
One system can take many different states.
I have just painted two of the states of this system.
But this system can have many more states.
Both these configurations are specific states of this system.
So, we have one box system
with four molecules in it.
Let's compare it with another system,
where we have a bigger box
with more molecules in the box.
Let's say two yellow molecules,
a blue molecule,
a green molecule,
here's a pink ... That's pretty fun.
I will also paint a light-colored molecule here
In this larger system, there are more molecule locations
and besides, there are more molecules.
So configurations or conditions will be more.
I drew a state, but they can be much more.
Imagine how molecules move constantly
in different directions, it will become clear to us that there are many different states,
which they can borrow.
And without even knowing what molecules are doing at this particular moment,
we can say that there are more possible states in this system,
than in this system, there are fewer possible states in it.
And because this system here has more possible states
more configurations you will need
to give you more information to find out where it is.
And for this system we can say that there is greater entropy.
When we talk about a mess, we actually mean it
the number of possible states of a thing.
And there is a logic, it is easy to imagine
that there are many more things to move here,
in many different directions
and with much more space for movement.
So this system is logical in general
to have more entropy.
When we talk about entropy, we do not mean any particular condition,
any particular configuration.
We are talking about the system as a whole,
without knowing where molecules are present.
In the room example, we talk about specific states.
"Scattered" and "clean" are two specific states.
But we do not mention the amount of configurations,
which a room could have.
In fact, if this room is larger,
there could be more configurations.
And at the molecular level,
if this room is warm, and this cold ...
or if this is simply greater, it means there are more molecules in it.
And these molecules can be arranged in many more configurations.
So it is possible for this room to have a higher entropy.
So, consider this justification, and let's go back
to the comparison of the Moon and the Sun.
Which one has higher entropy?
Let's think.
The sun is bigger, that is, many more molecules
And these molecules move much faster,
hotter and different.
While the moon is small, cold, with fewer molecules.
For the most part, it is hard,
there is no high temperature, which means that her molecules do not move much.
There are much less states, much less configurations than the Sun.
If we look at the Sun as a system,
his entropy is much greater than that of the moon.
Its entropy is much larger than the moon.
Think about how much information would we need?
We'll need a lot of information to find out where each molecule is located
or any atom of the moon.
But in the Sun we will need even more information to find out
where each molecule is located at any given time.
The sun is enormous, full of things moving.
And all of these molecules are very active.
I hope you're already beginning to understand what entropy is.
But maybe you'll think
"It's all very interesting, but why is it important?"
It is important because to some extent
we can describe the universe with the help of entropy.
As we know from the second law of thermodynamics,
entropy in the universe is constantly growing.
We are constantly going to the universe
with more possible conditions
and the consequences of this are very interesting.